starting off this hour is going to be
Johnny in Tennessee ain't Johnny
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you thank you for having me
sure what's up yes sir I just want to
get your take on the prosperity gospel
and prosperity preachers who say that
Christ died so that we could be wealthy
and healthy and prosperous but then you
had the other side of the question where
people and other believers say that it's
wrong to have money at all and I know
that as a as Christians and as believers
our greatest treasure is Christ himself
and that he died to give us himself and
to look for in forever
and so I just wanted to know your
thoughts on those both of those two
sides well you know I've been studying
this subject for probably 35 years and
trying to match it up with the reality
that I see around me and my tendency is
to believe that both ends of the
spectrum are exaggerating and therefore
in error right and we can talk about
that for a minute the the prosperity
side seems to indicate that if you're
poor then you must not have enough faith
which is ridiculous because that doesn't
match up with experiences that I've had
and you've had where we deal with people
that are poor and they've got many times
more faith and I'm more of a pure faith
and or that if you don't if you're not
healthy it's because you haven't prayed
properly I could because you didn't eat
properly you know right and so that that
kind of you know and because I talk
about money and I'm a Christian and I'm
unashamed
I'm unassigned about my success with
finances I often get lumped in on with
that trolls and the hate mail stuff that
Dave Ramsey's just one of those
prosperity Gospels and I'm definitely
not one of the priority preachers I I
don't believe that stuff now are there
are there elements of what they say that
are true sure absolutely and you can
find Scripture that indicates that
that an abundant life which is not
everything but money
it's everything including money an
abundant life is a good thing for a
Christian but an abundant life certainly
is more than money and if you limit it
to money and apply that scripture you
know Jesus is saying there to that then
that gets into a problem on the other
side it's often it's often funny to me
that the anti wealth is the people
quoting me scripture there are usually
not believers and sometimes they know
the scripture better than some believers
do and they'll say things like well
money is the root of all evil well it
doesn't say that in the Bible it says
the love it says the love of money is
the root of all kinds of evil it's very
clear and you know and to say that you
know my Heavenly Father who's absolutely
crazy about me if we being evil know how
to give our kids good gifts how much
more so our Father in Heaven and so you
know we're as parents I have this
inclination towards blessing my children
that comes from the fact that I'm made
in God's image and he has an inclination
towards blessing his children now does
that guarantee that somehow God you know
isn't participating in that of course
he's participating in the blessings for
those of us that believe in God you know
and so I'll bless others exactly you are
blessed that you might be a blessing and
I have noticed that poor people don't
feed hungry kids mm-hmm and so and so if
you say if you're on that side of the
spectrum from a spiritual perspective
you would say okay money is evil and
money's bad and you can't be a spiritual
person with money and so by definition
then you are surrendering the resources
of the world to people that are not
spiritual and they're supposed to do
good with it
so no instead we are called to be
stewards we're called to be managers and
faithful managers and trustworthy
managers and we you know
we have to plant because as you sow so
shall you reap
and and does it always work exactly no
but there are 30 almost 3000 scriptures
dealing with how to handle money and
almost and there's a few warnings about
wealth that it's dangerous it is
dangerous so sex it's dangerous but it's
also a gift from God for a married
couple right and so right you know
there's a lot of things power is
dangerous but when it's put in the hands
of someone who sees the power as a tool
to be used for the good of others the
good of God's kingdom then you're what's
called a steward you are a manager and
so this idea that you have to be poor in
order to be spiritual typed on someone's
$700 iPhone who makes 80 thousand
dollars a year when if you make thirty
eight thousand dollars a year your
household income you're the top 1% of
income earners in the world and so
almost everyone listening to me right
now is in the top of 1% of income
earners in the world and if if rich
people are all going to hell because the
camel can't get through the eye of a
needle then all of you listening or
going to hell based on the fact that you
got wealth which also completely
invalidates the work that was done at
the cross and so it's really blasphemy
right to say that Jesus's blood is not
enough to cover even those evil rich
people so it sits at what it is it's a
toxic twist on Scripture and we're where
I land is not really between those two
but would be off the on the third point
of the triangle because the scriptures
are real clear that there's a
cause-and-effect universe that we live
in our Heavenly Father is crazy about us
he wants good things for us but he's not
gonna give you something you can't
control so if you've not proven
trustworthiness with money then he's not
gonna give you money because it's gonna
bring harm to you and it's like I
wouldn't give my my Brent my 16 year old
who doesn't know how to drive well a
brand-new Corvette they kill themselves
because I'm a loving father and it
wouldn't be a blessed
it wouldn't be a blessing it'd be cursed
to give someone something they can't
control so just tons of scripture that
falls into all that so it's a great
discussion Johnny I appreciate you let
me get up on the soapbox a minute but um
you know the ones the ones that believe
that all things money are not spiritual
actually fall under the heading of what
we would call Gnosticism which were some
heretics of the first century Gnostics
were they were supposed Christians that
came to believe that anything physical
was evil and all things spiritual were
good and so everything physical is evil
and that's not what Scripture teaches
it teaches that we're supposed to take
dominion over physical things in order
to be a blessing to our families and to
others so cool discussion man thanks for
letting me yak about it for a minute
I'll send you a copy of our latest my
latest book which deals with this very
in-depth it's called the legacy journey
it's actually the only book I've written
that's purely a Christian book and it's
cut scripture upon Scripture upon
Scripture and deals a lot with this
issue
the legacy journey hold on Johnny thanks
for calling in